alireza farusia just fulfilled Magnus
Carlson's wish taking down the young and
talented Dennis logic to get one more
shot at the number one player in the
world it will be fun to play alireza
logic had an incredible run in the
Julius bear generation cup facing almost
every player in division one in the
losers bracket semi-final logific
discovered an incredible Mateen 13
attack to finish off no dierberg Abdus
toroff but when it came to the next
opponent logic's attacking style was
crushed by farugia with nearly a
five-point advantage in the second game
that lead started to deteriorate with
Rook E1 and then flipped with Rook D3
from there it was all faruja until a
forced mating sequence on the board 50
moves later after the game farugia had
some words of wisdom for the young
Prodigy it was a better player to them
that today when I was his age I was
losing to Fabiano level now Borussia has
his eyes locked on revenge against
Magnus who knocked him down to the
losers bracket three to nothing just the
day before